How's that work?
Who wants to lug around a big, heavy suitcase?
Well, there's a new product concept out there...
...that may replace your old suitcase.
Dubbed "Hop, The Following Suitcase,"...
...the luggage piece essentially follows its owner.
The suitcase reportedly utilizes a Bluetooth signal...
...that is hooked up to the owner's cell phone.
As the individual walks,...
...the suitcase trails after the person using the cell phone signals.
The inventor states...
..."A microcontroller operates a caterpillar system based on compressed air,..."
"...which follows the user at a constant distance."
As a nice security feature, if the phone loses signal,...
...the piece of luggage will automatically lock and vibrate the phone to alert the owner.
According to the designer,...
..."With current technology that is present today in lawn mowers or automatic vacuum cleaners,..."
"...a suitcase can embed the function of a bellhop."
While it may take some time for the moving suitcase to become commercially available,...
...many fliers can appreciate not being bogged down by heavy luggage.
Would you want to use it?